another legacy Marvel character may be
about to come bubbling to the surface of
the MCU a scene early in Avengers
endgame seems like it could be a hidden
tease for the impending arrival of Namor
the Submariner one of Marvel's oldest
characters an antihero with an 80-year
publication history Namor has served as
both a nemesis and an ally to a laundry
list of iconic Marvel heroes spoilers
for Avengers end game to follow
obviously fans have long wondered
whether Namor the Submariner would ever
make an appearance in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and endgame may have
actually given us our answer kind of
during the scene in question Scarlett
Johansson's Natasha Romanoff is
convening a holographic Council of
heroes who are scattered after the
five-year jump one of the participants
is oak oyez who appears to be holding
Wakanda together in the absence of the
dusted King T'Challa she reports seismic
activity on the floor of the Atlantic
Ocean under the African plate which
apparently falls under wakanda's
jurisdiction when asked by Romanoff how
she intends to handle it Ocoee says it's
an earthquake under the ocean we handle
it by not handling it at first it seems
like a throwaway line but if we know
Marvel it was included for a purpose and
we have a couple key pieces of evidence
to back up our assertion the fact that
the disturbance was reported by Ocoee is
telling as Wakanda and Atlantis have a
bit of a history in the comics that is
to say they don't get along and have
actually gone to war on more than one
occasion not only that in the second
issue of the original Infinity Gauntlet
miniseries and undersea earthquake
occurs in the wake of Thanos is snap and
none other than Namor the Submariner is
on-hand to investigate more importantly
than all that though is the fact that
Marvel Studios is well known for
planting seeds which suggests the
possibility of characters that might
come up into play down the line and this
particular seed was not the first one
that's been planted in the MCU
concerning me more way back in 2010 Iron
Man 2 there
a scene in which Nick Fury and Tony
Stark discussed tentative plans to scout
for the team that would soon become the
Avengers
during their conversation fury was
referring to a series of holographic
screens many of which depicted events
from the past and the future in the MCU
but one screen was simply a world map
which showed various hotspots around the
globe which had garnered the interest of
shield and one of those hotspots happen
to be located smack in the middle of the
Atlantic Ocean
of course it's almost certain that at
the time that particular Easter Egg was
dropped nobody had any idea whether
Namor would ever come into play in the
MCU but the inclusion of Ocoee Ezra port
and Avengers and games suggests that
Marvel Studios might have kept the
character in mind this entire time and
that they may now be prepping us for his
formal introduction
speaking of introductions Namor first
appeared in motion picture funnies
weekly at number one a promotional
publication handed out to movie theaters
all the way back in April 1939 this book
was in fact the very first to ever be
published by the company that would
later become Marvel Comics making Namor
not just a legacy character but the
legacy character named Moore's origin
story and characteristics are quite
similar to that of DCs Aquaman who
wouldn't appear until November of 1941
the half-human son of an Atlantean
princess he's a prince and later king of
that underwater realm whose mistrust of
the surface world runs deep he's super
strong super tough and yes he can also
communicate with marine life so yeah in
all ways that matter he's basically the
original Aquaman but this guy can fly
his worst pep talk ever given the huge
success Warner Brothers saw with Aquaman
it wouldn't be a huge stretch for Marvel
Studios to try and show their super
heroic rivals their own take on an
undersea adventure meanwhile with the
death of Ironman the tire man of Captain
America and the departure of Thor for
space with the guardians of the galaxy
Marvel still needs some action to go
down on earth
what better character to bring onto the
scene than their original super guy
Namor not only that but Marvel finally
has access to
Fantastic Four now that Disney has
acquired 20th Century Fox considering
name Wars deep ties to the FF and the
comics the time might finally be right
for Marvel's under-seat King they show
the surface world who's boss check out
one of our newest videos right here Plus
even more looper videos about Avengers
endgame are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]